fire
no single tool in the human Arsenal
explains our existence more than fire
from an animal like any other to the
dominant species on earth because we
figured out how to steal from the
heavens and harness the power of the Sun
was a piece of magic so exceptional so
inexplicable we told our children was a
gift from the gods and turned it into a
myth to be handed down for thousands of
these years
heat nourishment transportation
communication annihilation fire made us
warriors and builders and explorers
with each advance we paid with our blood
but still we kept going and today we
break through the bonds of Earth escape
archeage the only thing we see when we
look back is the light of our greatest
conquest like a flame that cannot be
extinguished drive within us to create
expand and dominate not just this world
but the next the very spark of humanity
starts here with fire
this is origins
[Music]